normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
NBC News I love this how the GOP muzzled
the quiet Coalition that fought foreign
propaganda o that sounds like the gop's
up to no good what's this all about the
FBI put a pause on briefings with tech
companies due to an ongoing lawsuit
adding to a broader breakdown in a
system meant to guard against influence
operations and to ensure election
integrity I don't buy it for a second
these people are evil as evil can be but
let me read you the opening paragraph a
once robust Alliance of federal agencies
tech companies election officials and
researchers that work together to thwart
foreign propaganda and disinformation
has fragmented after years of sustained
Republican attacks man just reads their
propaganda are so mean to the FBI they
just descriptive an illegal and
unconstitutional conspiracy between
intelligence agencies and tech companies
to silence the opinions of American
citizens has been thwarted and they're
crying about it you know what's really
funny when these things happen the one
thing you got to do is look to who gets
laid off what's this around the same
time that NBC is reporting the
fracturing of this government Coalition
there's a bunch of layoffs being
reported at various digital media
Outlets I wonder why that is how much do
you want to bet the federal government
is illicitly supplying funding to
digital media companies to hire people
specifically for the purpose of lying to
manipulate the public didn't Vice just
lay off some more people and then
completely shut down Jezebel's gone yeah
yeah Jezebel but that's just a public
service you know that that's good for no
coincidence yeah no coincidence and
they're like you know what our business
isn't aligned and I'm not saying that
these companies are funded by the CIA or
anything like that but there
are there if if you do the research and
there's a lot of stories that we've
we've talked about over the over the
years and stories that I've covered
several years ago you do often see this
there is government programs that
provide funding that typically get used
for propagandistic efforts we know that
the federal government provides
craploads of Monies to public radio
which gets they do this this game where
it's like NPR doesn't get government
funding and then it turns out that no
some other organization gets funding
which then provides funding to NPR so
it's circuitous but we see what you're
doing the CIA would never never fund
something to further push their interest
they've never done that right but I do
think it's interesting and that's all
I'm saying I am not saying I have any
evidence I it's very interesting that
whenever you get these stories of like
government programs ending there's a
bunch of layoffs in the corporate press
huh how about that how about that so uh
what's the story about the tech
companies were colluding with the
government to suppress the free speech
of American citizens in violation of the
First Amendment they got caught the
Republicans are shutting them down and
now they're winging about it do you
think people read this for sentence uh a
once robust Alliance of federal agencies
tech companies election officials and
researchers and think these are the
people I want to have
an this sounds like it really is looking
out for me the word integrity that's
true it it means the opposite right uh
but I I just wonder if the average
American looks at this and says oh they
are trying to pull over me because
people don't trust the government some
do some portions of Voters really trust
it but a lot of Voters are skeptical of
it and so it makes me think if you saw
these words strung together you'd be
like this is a good thing we don't want
this once robust but the way they write
it they act like it's such a big tragedy
these these people are abject evil I'm
sorry the CCP is evil I think a l i
can't speak too much to Vladimir Putin
because I don't know enough about Russia
but he appears to do many things that I
would describe as self-interested and
evil but the CCP I think Takes the Cake
Russia may be a bit more vague and
emulous in terms of bad though CCP is is
just abject evil we can see the things
they do uh in terms of militaristic
expansion the way they seize property
the way they control the lives of the
people who live in China the videos of
people being tortured by police yeah
it's not a fun place to live I'm not
saying Russia is but you know they're
not as bad as a CCP still I'm not a big
fan of Putin but uh these intelligence
agencies and the things they're doing
this is evil I'm sorry they might sit
there and think I'm the good guy no
you're a crackpot evil desperate who
thinks that your is better than someone
else's and you have a right to dictate
what they think and do you don't you
don't I'll tell you what my view is my
view is more like if the American people
believe stupid things they're allowed to
believe stupid things and then the
intelligence agencies are like but but
we have to go fight Putin and if the
American people are doing stupid things
will fail I'm like that's too bad a
decentralized system is better than a
centralized one and here's why if it is
that 60% of the Americans are so dumb
they vote for a dumb policy which causes
problems for this country and serious
ones
it is better than if you have one
crackpot who believes tons of crackpot
things and then drives the country into
the toilet what appears to be happening
now is this country is no longer
operating in a decentralized way so we
are getting hyper centralized I
ideologically driven crackpot Decisions
by the Deep state which is destroying
the country and then in the meantime
they're saying but it's everyone else
who's the problem dude let Grandma post
her stupid memes on Facebook
let people be wrong and let the best
ideas win you when you try to control
everything and regulate everything we we
look there's a great meme Luke posted
Luke rowski posted and it's the private
sector from 1950 to today and the public
sector from 1950 to today and guess what
the private sector it's like you know
this this gigantic box computer in a
warehouse and then a cell phone and the
public sector it's everything's the
exact same nothing improves what what
these people do is they they're stuck in
this stagnant reality where they can't
adjust to the changing world and they
think that the pro the the solutions are
going to be 50-year-old solutions they
think that they have to control the
minds of the American people but this
stagnates our ability to solve our own
problems so how about you let Grandma
post her memes you shut up and we'll
vote for who we want to vote for because
we would be infinitely better off if
Donald Trump won in 2020 than where we
are today with a crippled economy on the
verge of World War III hey y'all lost
the Ukraine war I don't even think Putin
would have invaded if Donald Trump was
President here we are next thing that's
going to happen is China's going to
invade Taiwan and Joe B's going to go
bro come on man and if Donald Trump was
president at the very least these things
would be happening slower but I also
think they probably wouldn't be
happening at all well you see you see
this the parallels between how sensitive
the CCP is about controlling information
and about criticism within their own
country and it's almost like America is
I mean I'd say slowly but more now now
fastly shifting to that same direction
of you have to censor online you have to
absolutely control Grandma's memes
online even if they're inaccurate or if
they're accurate and it's like America
is essentially becoming the exact same
thing that the CCP is trying to control
and centralize all this information and
they're just so sensitive you can't
critique the FBI you can't critique
these agencies and if you do you're
going to get censored yeah I mean it
makes me think about the Twitter files
right when when Twitter files got
released mainstream media was sort of
like we don't want to acknowledge that
we all knew this all along and now we
definitely have evidence that there's
collusion between tech companies and
federal agencies and instead L later
they're like how could you guys ruin our
awesome relationship that we're actually
very proud of it seems like such a
strange world and the American voter is
just expected to to go along with it
right I think that's the most insulting
part communism they didn't expect Elon
Musk to buy Twitter oh I know it's
amazing a fun plot twist and and and
vayia was crying and I bet she cried a
lot but but not because it's like oh no
an evil man is going to make hate speech
no cuz she's like he's going to find
what I said and that's what happened and
then you know here's here's the crazy
thing too I wish that Elon just dumped
all of it oh yeah he didn't it was
select it was searched and there's
reasons for it I mean there's going to
be stuff in there about passwords
there's going to be stuff in there about
financials that's too bad I I I really
wish he was just like I I bought uh
Twitter and I'm going to publish
everything their entire servers are not
open to the public have fun well V on
Luke radowski's podcast after the uh the
uh debate debate yeah if I can speak
today um he laid out like almost a good
fiveyear plan about basically releasing
Twitter files but for all social media
agencies and just really exposing how
deep all of this goes and how deep the
CIA and the FBI actually meddle into it
the's basically going up on stage and
being like anyone who's paying attention
to what's going on I have your answers
the problem is to win votes you probably
have to
like there's a reason why these
politicians behave the way they do
because VI going up there and saying
listen this is a thing that's happening
a lot of people are going to be like
what's he talking about and then you're
going to get Ronda s or Nikki Haley
saying some you know blathering about
some mindless platitudes and it just
sounds good I think there is a very
serious division between uh those on
Twitter and those who are not on Twitter
in America and it's it is weird I mean
news moves much faster on Twitter and
there's information that circulates that
becomes fact uh not saying it isn't fact
but you know comes more publicly known
and then you'll get voters who don't use
Twitter or who are just only really on
Instagram maybe check Facebook once a
while and I I honestly applaud those
people right they're they're probably
just living their lives having a good
time on the other hand they are not
aware and maybe they would feel the
urgency uh but they aren't moving as
rapidly as everyone else it's like
painful to watch every day but you have
to otherwise if you miss a week then you
miss so much but some people can't they
have other things to do you know the
meme of the two guys on the bus and one
guy's looking at at the dreary rocks and
the guy looking at the the the the you
know the valley in the sun and the guy
looking at the sun is smiling and the
guy looking at the cliff is sad someone
posted that it might have been I don't
want to I don't want to drag the wrong
account but it was an account I follow
and the guy looking at the dreary
Cliffside it said people who read the
news or people who watch the news and
then the people smiling is said people
who don't watch the news and I was like
the problem with that is that it's
technically the other way around a lot
of people are like man the news is so
depressing though yeah but here's the
thing what it should is if you want to
do that the guy who's watching the news
is sad but he's alive and the guy who's
not watching the news has a bunch of
needles in his back has a guy stealing
money out of his back pocket his kids
are being dragged Away by a Creo and
he's just like I have no idea what's
going on and I don't care and it makes
me happy it's like let the world
collapse all around you let your
children be indoctrinated and groomed
your money be taken to blow up kids to
get injected full of crazy whatever
drugs the doctor you know is claiming
you got to get and that's when you don't
know what's going on in the world
you don't pay attention you and your
family suffer and they suffer for future
the future Generations suffer those are
the same people that you know say oh as
long as it doesn't affect me doing X or
this you know if I as long as I can get
a beer at the end of the day then uh you
know it doesn't worry me it worries you
very quickly when things start hitting
the fan as they are right now yeah yeah
I think sorry you going to say oh well I
was just going to say Tim we had a I
think um genocide losing my mind reached
it was our year anniversary for that a
couple days ago I was reading a comment
and some was like anyone back here A
year later thinking like wow they knew
ahead of time crazy cuz like it was
before the Ukraine thing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net